hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome back to
another high definition screencast video
and to be honest this isn't actually
another high definition tutorial this is
just an example of a piece of software
that i think if you are a geek or if you
are a windows user or anyone who is like
concerned about
the protection of their computer i'm
showing you a piece of freeware that i
think you should absolutely know about
so you're looking at it right now it's
called ccleaner it is available at
ccleaner.com
right now it is what i believe to be
absolutely the best maintenance software
for your computer whether you have a
laptop or a desktop
so basically what the software does is
help you
maintain a very very clean computer
whether you're editing your registry or
using their cleanup tools to disable
startup programs or just using the
cleaner to just disable things or remove
things that have been accumulated in
your pc over time
so an example of that if we stay under
the cleaner tab uh you can see under
internet explorer when we hit run
cleaner it's going to clean out all the
things that are checked so right now
it's going to clean out a lot of
internet explorer a lot of windows
explorer cache
a lot of cash other things like that
clean up desktop shortcuts that are
unused you can clean up a lot of things
that you don't feel like leaving on your
computer when you shut down
so this is actually software that i
actually do run on every single computer
i have before i shut it down it's
absolutely critical
so you can either clean stuff under
windows or under applications so under
apps you can see you can clear all the
things under opera all things under
safari a whole bunch of things under
firefox which i actually do like
although i do leave uh form information
unchecked uh clean up chrome clean up
clean up uh all these other different
applications and once you've done this
instead of just hitting analyze you can
hit and run cleaner and it'll go ahead
and analyze and then run
i'll just go ahead and analyze to show
you it'll go ahead and analyze your
entire computer
this won't take very long if your hard
drive is fast or if you have a solid
state drive
and once you're done with that you can
see all the things that will be cleaned
and that's a good amount of files and
you can see you'll probably remove about
47.2 megabytes just from using my
computer from a few hours go ahead and
hit run cleaner
and clean out those 47 megabytes of
files that a discovery don't need which
is very very nice so i do run this every
single time i shut down my computer
another thing ccleaner does as you can
tell is clean out your registry now it
is called ccleaner because it's built to
clean your c drive
which is basically what it was meant to
do but it does have a registry cleaner
and you can check every single thing for
it to go through your registry to look
for
installer files that you don't need
anymore
unused fonts different things that are
in your cache that you don't need and
obsolete software and all sorts of
things that you don't need on your
computer anymore that are just active in
messing up with your registry your
registry is actually what keeps your
computer really really fast and if you
have a good solid state drive and you
keep your computer organized your your
registry won't get messed up as easily
so go ahead and check everything and hit
scan for issues
and you're going to see a whole lot of
things that you you either don't need or
don't want on your computer so unused
file extensions etc this is really cool
to have or to know about go ahead and
hit fix selected issues
fix all selected issues and just like
that instantly you saw in the background
all eight issues were just fixed which
is really nice and you can actively
maintain your registry this way
now being that we're also on a netbook
at the moment you're also going to want
to go into tools and just go ahead and
take some of the things off of the
startup folder you don't really want a
whole lot of things starting with your
pc
so if you go under startup you'll be
able to see all the things that do start
with your computer i've kind of
minimized minimized it already
i'm going ahead and go ahead and right
click and disable anything that i don't
want starting with my computer
uh there are a whole lot of things that
you might not actually want starting
with your computer that'll actually save
you a lot of time
uh in terms of startup times and
especially with a solid state drive
you'll get the most out of this go ahead
and make sure you've gone through all
that you can also uninstall applications
you don't use very quickly through
ccleaner as well
so that's just a basic overview of
ccleaner if you have any questions about
it you can first visit ccleaner.com and
if you have any quick questions you can
leave a comment or message me through
youtube and i'll try to get back to you
as quickly as possible
until next time this has been mkbhd with
a quick rundown of a piece of software i
definitely think you should just go out
and get right now the link to
cccleaner.com will be in the description
so thank you for watching peace